Cutting-edge effects technology isn't always
used to create cool explosions and giant robots.
Released nearly 30 years after the original
film, Tron: Legacy is a computerized adventure
packed with light cycles and Daft Punk music.
Most importantly, this 2010 Disney film gave
audiences double the Dude.
Jeff Bridges returned to the Tron universe
as two separate characters.
First, there's the heroic Kevin Flynn, who
looks exactly like the older actor.
But then there's Clu, the artificial intelligence
gone rogue.
And while he was played by a man in his 60s,
this evil computer program looks more or less
like Bridges did back in the '80s.
VFX supervisor Eric Barba oversaw the transformation.
He achieved it with a four-camera, head-mounted
system that Bridges wore on the set to get
a floating, 3D point cloud of his face.
The effect may look a little "computery,"
but that's okay because, after all, Clu is
a computer program.
The tragic death of Paul Walker in 2013 sent
a massive shockwave through the Fast and Furious
community.
After all, this is a franchise about family,
and both Walker and his character of Brian
O'Conner were super important to a whole lot
of people.
His death had serious implications for the
production of Furious 7, as the actor died
during filming.
Fortunately, Weta Digital was able to save
the day and preserve Walker's legacy for Fast
and Furious fans around the world.
The folks at Weta digitally created a whopping
350 shots of Walker doing everything from
jumping skyscrapers to standing in a lineup
with the rest of his crew.
Additionally, Walker's brothers, Caleb and
Cody, and actor John Brotherton gave motion
capture performances that Weta used to recreate
Brian.
Thanks to their incredible work, he got to
ride with his family one last time.
When Kevin Spacey was accused by multiple
victims of sexual assault, director Ridley
Scott made one of the gutsiest decisions in
Hollywood history.
Spacey and Scott had recently finished working
on All the Money in the World when the scandal
broke.
Unwilling to keep Spacey in the film, Scott
replaced the actor with Christopher Plummer,
reshooting every scene featuring Spacey's
character, stingy billionaire J. Paul Getty.
It was an unprecedented move, and it cost
$10 million to exorcise Spacey from the film.
Most of these scenes were done practically,
with other actors on actual sets, but there
is one quick moment in which Scott resorted
to some digital trickery.
For a scene in which Getty goes to Jordan,
it was too impractical to go all the way back
to the Middle East.
So Plummer was shot in front of a green screen,
and after the special effects crew digitally
erased Spacey, they just slid Plummer right
into place.
2017's Blade Runner 2049 was a beautiful follow-up
to the original 1982 Blade Runner.
It saw the return of Harrison Ford as Rick
Deckard, but he wasn't the only original cast
member to come back.
During one key scene, the aging Deckard is
confronted by a ghost from his past.
It's Rachael, the replicant he fell in love
with in the first film.
Only this isn't the Rachael that Deckard remembers.
That Rachael is dead.
This is a new, shiny one, created solely to
tempt Deckard to the dark side.
And this isn't exactly the actress we remember,
either.
In order to de-age Sean Young by over 30 years,
the Moving Picture Company analyzed photos
of her, studied scenes from the first film,
and even checked out Young's other performances
from around the same era.
They also photographed Young with a special
device that captured her likeness from multiple
angles.
With all these references, they were able
to create a CGI face they could then layer
onto a body double, who shot the scene with
Ford, with Young standing by as an adviser.
Unlike many digital creations, the Rachael
of 2049 looks incredibly lifelike, which is
kind of perfect for a movie that wonders what
makes us human.
In this film about adult friends playing a
game of Tag for years and years, Jeremy Renner
is an uncatchable man.
He's been evading his buddies by moving like
an Olympic athlete and dodging outstretched
hands like he's in the Matrix.
During one of these escape scenes, Renner
jumped on top of a huge stack of chairs, which
resulted in disaster when the rigging that
held the chairs in place snapped and sent
him tumbling.
When Renner got up, he realized he'd broken
both his arms.
As he explained to Entertainment Weekly, he
could still move his limbs "up and down kind
of like a robot," so he didn't need too much
digital assistance.
However, there is one moment when the VFX
crew had to create a completely CG arm, and
it's in the very scene where his stunt went
wrong, specifically when he tosses a donut
at Ed Helms.
Needless to say, we're legitimately impressed
that Renner could deal with all that pain
and continue filming.